C'est d'ailleurs là où Joe Biden
a terminé sa tournée européenne,
en critiquant durement Vladimir
Poutine.
(musique militaire)
- L'instant d'une journée,
le quartier général des efforts
antirusses s'est déplacé en
Pologne.
(inaudible)
Le président américain est venu
rassurer un allié clé.
Joe Biden souligne que
la Pologne prend de très grandes
responsabilités, qui devraient
être partagées entre alliés.
Il est notamment question
des centaines de milliers
d'Ukrainiens accueillis par
le voisin polonais.
Le président est allé à
la rencontre d'Ukrainiennes qui
ont laissé des frères ou des
conjoints derrière.
Là-bas, il s'est assuré que
personne nutututait de ses
véritables sentiments.
Joe Biden compare Vladimir
Poutine à un boucher, après
l'avoir traité de criminel de
guerre et de voyou.
Des mots durs, mais l'Ukraine
réclame davantage.
Le ministre ukrainien des
Affaires étrangères espère que
les États-Unis sauront
convaincre l'Europe de punir
davantage la Russie.
Une demande à laquelle
Joe Biden a faito o o dans
un discours inspiré de la lutte
des pays d'Europe de l'Est
contre l'Union soviétique.
Il réclame que l'Europe brise
rapidement sa dépendance aux
énergies russes. Joe Biden a
répété que les troupes de l'OTAN
n'iraient pas affronter les
Russes en Ukraine.
(applaudissements)
Mais il a été ferme, l'Alliance
ferait tout pour défendre chaque
pouce carré de son territoire.
Une posture agressive, un
président qui semble certain
d'être du bon côté de
l'histoire.
"Pour l'amour de Dieu, implore
Joe Biden, Vladimir Poutine ne
peut rester au pouvoir."
Joe Biden a laeueueueueuple
russe qu'il ne méritait pas
la guerre, et toutes
ses conséquences économiques.
Entre les lignes, il semble
leur demander de stopper
leur président. Reste à savoir
si les Russes ont même entendu
le message.
Yanik Dumont-Ba
Radio-Canada, Varsovi